hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
seeing how this is February the month of
romance based around a saint that you're
uniquely lazy-ass will never bother to
research I think we should dedicate this
enchanted time of year to the month of
love and what better way to start off
this month of love then the loved one
gives to a child no no and your jacuzzi
a barbed wire and hell is waiting for
you I'm talking about the love from
parent to child as demonstrated in the
odd life of Timothy green this is the
story about a couple who can't have a
child until one magically appears in the
backyard and shows them the quirks and
whimsy of what it means to be a parent
now granted a lot of people didn't like
this film when it first came out in fact
many declared they'd rather pass a
marble bag of kidney stones but I'm sure
such an innocent story couldn't have
anything that horrible in it how bad
could something like this possibly be
something so adorable and lovable and
cute and absolutely charming my
apologies to the neighbor's cat it's
just after seeing a film that was so cat
Killingly bad I had no choice but to
destroy the nearest living creature
I mean Wow Wow
God Jesus Wow heaven above Lord shit
fuck
Wow this film is horrendous
I mean it's got awful I can rip into
this shitstorm so much that that's
exactly what I'm gonna do this is the
odd terribly disturbed life of Timothy
green
I'm sorry Walt
the film opens with a couple played by
Jennifer Garner and Joel Edgerton we're
filling out the paperwork to apply for
adopting a child oh wait you didn't
answer what makes you qualified oh we
know there wasn't much space we had too
much to say
okay idiots word of advice if you're
reasoning wouldn't work on your second
great teacher chances are it wouldn't
work on the United States adoption
services I mean really there wasn't
enough space that's what you're going
with
imagine using that excuse somewhere else
in life here's my test mrs. Travers
um you failed to answer every single
question listed I know I just had so
much information I could put down for
all of them I decided not to I'm sorry
that means you get an F is in fantastic
know as in vail as it failed not to be
fantastic know as an you failed the test
as in I failed the test of not failing
the exam you so currently gave to me are
you still here I need a mommy so they
convinced the adoption agency to listen
to their story about why there wasn't
enough space you're gonna find it hard
to believe this all began last September
it turns out the doctors say that Garner
is unable to get pregnant which forces
them to drive back to Stanley bill the
pencil capital of the world
oh and I'm not kidding they really want
you to remember that Stanley bill is the
pencil capital of the world they show
countless footage of pencils being may
they have a soccer team called the
erasers Edgerton works for a pencil
factory Garner is a tour guide in a
museum dedicated to pencils by the time
the movie is over you want to eat the
goddamn things but our couple doesn't
seem to have much of an appetite as
they're still heartbroken about garner
being as unfruitful as their vegetable
garden sure you can't do it I can't move
on then move out of the way years we've
been thinking about what our kid would
have been like we can move on tomorrow
just for tonight can we have a kid see
how this might sound like a fucking
radical idea but huh why not an
orphanage yeah a little weird seeing how
the film opens up with them at the
orphanage so it's not like this never
crossed their minds if having a child
meant so much to you why didn't you just
do that before were they afraid that
something like Timothy might actually
come to life and therefore
to turn another child down are my new
parents nice they certainly are and
they're gonna give you a good home Hey
I can't wait to have a real mom and dad
oh I'm so sorry it says here that
they've grown a child in the backyard
has absolutely perfect in every way in
which case they don't have any need for
you anymore no me none I'm sorry I know
it's the third time this month man fuck
this shit I'm 18 I'm still not adopted
but they decide to fantasize for just
one night and thus the billikin workshop
is open what I could be musical sergeant
Rock love and be loved how great an ass
are you patreon you were terrible at
soccer her kid amazing kid got to score
the winning goal
ah could you not show how into you are
in such a loud scary way so they put
their drawings of blood vaginas in a box
and buried in the backyard convinced
they can now move on with their lives
but then so we get our first look at
children of the corn who has leaves on
his ankles and apparently is thoroughly
convinced that he has always belonged to
this couple call us mr. and mrs. Briggs
agree not many people do mom really dad
so of course they have to fill out a
report or go to the police or put out
posters saying missing child I'm getting
that kidnapping works too I'm always
trying to meet people don't consider
that option I mean when you look past
the hole you eagle and emotionally
scarring thing it's actually pretty
logical you know you can't drum into the
authorities guys it's not like et they
have walkie-talkies now instead of guns
oh wait they changed it back in the DVD
version ten they do run Jimmy run so
Garner's sister shows up the next day
and our new parents try to explain the
appearance of our little friend it was
all very sudden Minh kind of miraculous
oh you mean II thought you were trying
to have a real kid let's add her to the
list of horrible pieces of human shit in
this film trust me
Callisto crow in fact there's one right
now edgerton's father who apparently
spent most of his time away from his son
who has resented him ever since
but Timmy hopes he can win his
grandfather over with a trailer shot
you
yes he must be doing this because he's a
plant and therefore basking when the Sun
comes out except for the fact that the
Sun was clearly out several other times
before but the cameraman wasn't ready
for his 360 shot yet
his grandfather X according Oh what did
you say to your father after he bunked
the boy with leaves in the head
complicated I didn't say anything really
and yes the adoption agency is still
listening to the story and allowing them
to continue because if I ran an adoption
agency I'd say to myself yeah this is
worth my valuable time not turning these
people away and instead looking for
parents who don't think the Cabbage
Patch Kids are based on true story I've
listened to I can only imagine what that
guy is writing down on his nope a the
whole time
oh my god we almost took the focus of
this movie away from pencils worst case
scenario
my aunt my father I have no choice but
to close the factory
Edgerton is called away from the pencil
pushers as it appears Timmy has been
beaten up at school this kind of thing
happened to me when I was your age yeah
and all I wanted was for my dad to have
my back and he didn't bottom line as
long as you come out is with a healthy
hatred of your grandfather I'll consider
myself a good father but oh it turns out
the father of those bullies is actually
his boss what good matted my boys out
are you really gonna fight all his
battles for him II think that's wise why
can't you be like me let my kids get
away with murder
next Saturday we're having a birthday
party pool bash and we'd love it if
Timothy would come yes oh please don't
tell me you took him back to the house
of the boys who bullied him he really
wanted to go so you let him decide what
was best I thought it was time he
learned to fight his own battles we just
forgot to ask if he could swim and
you're probably starting to see what the
main problem with this movie is not the
fact that they're telling a story that
nobody not kicked by a horse could
believe or that they live in a town with
more umbra jerks than a TLC show oh
don't get me wrong girls are great
things to hate but the parenting in this
movie is awful I mean really really
awful they're trying to tell the story
to show how much they've learned but all
we ever see is them constantly
acknowledge that they always make the
wrong choices oh is that gonna win him
over we were gonna have the talk that we
didn't really know how to have that was
the plan to talk and here's another
little annoying timid they do a lot in
this movie
the couple completes their sentences a
little too often everything had changed
their us leave so no matter where he
came from he was ours yeah we were his
you were a family we were
when I say a little too often I mean all
the fucking time how do you tell your
child something's not possible that it
can't be done when they believe in you
like that well we didn't want to
disappoint no we got busy
I'm sure again this is to show how in
tune they are but it's pretty obnoxious
I mean they just never stop doing it
I loved once to see a couple complete
each other sentences without getting
right what the other was going to say it
didn't matter where he came from he was
ours where is we were a family
it was the greatest day since he
discovered viagra that wasn't what a
penis should look like until you started
taking it maybe if you let me finish she
would say all the time but nothing ever
came out I don't think we should talk
about this without visual if Christ
would cry every night until I showed him
the online ads Damon honey this is only
hard enough was the name of the brand we
got this is why we can't have children
can we just go back to talking about the
child that we grew in the backyard I
think we're winning over much better
with that right
what's the straight face oh and just to
make things better
let's throw prepubescent lust into the
mix
all right thank one of my students is
beginning to grow
now I'm guessing that's the mating dance
of mulch Jimmy seems to stay underwater
for a while and since the world's
greatest parents are nowhere to be found
the girl dives in after him
ultimately discovering Timmy's little
secret nobody touches the leaves dance
use all right folks sweet isn't Immy
kicked up girl he has a crush on right
dab in the schnauzer she's cute when
they set by your own battles I didn't
underwater flash kicks
oh man speaking of fighting your own
battles what advice to mom and dad of
the year have to give what do I do about
the girl I kicked in the head Jim well
if you see your coming just run the
other way hey kids let's play a game
it's called politicians one second I'll
say one thing and then another moment
I'll say something totally different I
thought it was time he learned to fight
his own battles just run the other way I
thought it was time you learned to fight
his own back destrun the other way fight
his own back we run the other way fight
his own back we're on the other way now
let's play another game pick it school
start making sex you're fucking tall
what she takes the whole having leaves
on his ankle thing unrealistically well
as it turns out she has a jelly stain in
the shape of Wisconsin on her chest so I
guess that means they have something in
common
of course her secret is minor in
pedestrian where he is a living
abomination of nature but we have to
have something for this forest for
romance to go off of
look out your window you told him to run
the other way when he started
not running but Timmy's parents don't
like this at all because I have no
fucking idea we don't know a thing about
her she's done nothing wrong and yet
they advise Timmy to constantly stay
away from her there are so many girls it
would be a mistake to focus on just one
fish what we're trying to say son is
stay away from the girl we know nothing
about exploring her differences could
only get the way of isolating her more
this movies too hard to watch and I need
a break we'll be right back after these
people try to sell you something
he mum and did
or should I say Lisa and Bob are you
depressed that you can have a child of
your own or you said that the miracle
childbirth will never take place in your
life do you find it unbearable that you
will never know the gift of creation the
growth of the young or the unconditional
love that any human being can ever give
to you as long as you live are you tired
of your shriveled up
dode well cry no more cuz we've invented
chit chit chat child G it shut the
instructions are very simple just write
down exactly what you would like your
chia child to be like place it in the
chia child box bury it in the backyard
just add God and she a child is yours I
always wanted a girl with no
imperfections at all just like a real
child chit chit chit child I always
dreamed of a little someone that could
project my insecurities on to and as
soon as that she's arrived look I can
picture about how much I hate
grandfather because you didn't raise e
right and now I get to pass down a
hatred to you should teach a child GHL
would last up to three months or until
you feel the emotional and symbolic
justification of what it means to be a
family I'll admit at first we didn't
think we'd be very good parents but ghl
seems to be calm and pleasant no matter
what horrible mistakes we make so now we
don't have to worry about any of that
pesky moral responsibility chia child
simply combines these natural elements
to give you that lovable family that
you've seen in most Sears catalogues and
when she a child has worn out her
usefulness just bury her in the backyard
and he had another one
I'm so glad something like chia child
exists yeah I mean if you know how long
it takes to adopt a child 18 months now
I can get a gun in a week now make me a
sandwich man we're not a child the child
that grows when your parenting blows
available in daughter Lily answer
they sent Timmy up for soccer class even
though he has no talent in this board
and doesn't really have much interest
even rappers are looking to tell their
wives there I did a damn kids movie
agree this would be really good friend
this is the best possible way for him to
make some friends close Cal doesn't see
coach Cal like speaking to the third
person coach Cal thinks of an old crusty
white man like Bob Dole can do it Coach
Cal can too but coach Cal signs him up
anyway because coach Cal likes losing
excusing coaching I just want to say
that I'll be working with him around the
clock necessary just get him you know
tell me you're not those kind of parents
the type to get old involve
over-invested we are definitely not
those kind of parent we never get
invested in what our kid does he will
drown the other day then we won't have a
problem but this is all fine and good
but can we find some way to bring this
back to pencils that Halloween your mom
went as a pencil it feels to me that
with a pencil anything is possible
that is so true yes pencils are land
filled goddesses of the universe a don't
you forget to think that we may not be
making these anymore
why not make a new kind of pencil didn't
you hear the pencil is already perfect
to the design it will be too late design
ever
so they decide to make a new pencil one
made entirely out of leaves yeah I know
I called bullshit too but not as much
bullshit as this scene where garner
takes Timmy to her work and her boss
play by Dianne Wiest is not thrilled
about her new portrait little man what
do you think of that not much I would
have done it for free you're suggesting
you could do it better
I can try let's find out he has only ten
years old it's somewhere to be of course
I do but shoo okay just leave me in a
room alone with your son who had only
known for a few minutes and yet I am
instantly forcing a challenge onto so of
course Timmy naturally draws her
my heart was pounding the whole time it
was the most erotic moment of my life
of course the picture looks great but
unfortunately he adds a little too much
detail in the go chin Department watch
garner once again be a great role model
for her kid
so what else aren't you telling men
sometimes you wear plaids and stripes
The Clash you're one joke that you
always tell it's not funny I have tried
so hard to like you but if someone asked
me to be a pallbearer at your funeral
I would tell them not by the hair of my
chinny-chin-chin
and furthermore Sinnott lost your job I
lost my job oh that's fine I mean at
least you still had the other job that
we've been discussing the last hour and
a half is gonna go out of business and
most likely we be financially stranded
ah he didn't know what he was doing with
the girls so Cindy did what she thought
was best
oh this can only make you look better We
Need to Talk hey let's talk I don't
think that you're the best influence on
my son and I want you to tell me what
you know about him what what did she do
lady well I checked your kid nailed her
in the packing head who's a bad
influence on who what's a hard world to
be different in honey wanting to be hurt
by you or anyone I won't let it happen I
see the way you pay attention to him as
your concern in his life I think it's
sick so she finds out they were building
a little hideout for each other and that
the girl she had no reason to hate boy
she has no reason to hate so maybe this
will teach her not to be so hasty with
her decisions even with her contrived
unrealistically nasty sister did you
know Timothy is gifted Hausa
he always finds a bright side why get
you into college I was a great artist
before that got you I have to say I am
I'm listening I'm just checking to see
if my name's replaced the c-word yet
he's musical
really yeah so she makes up a lie about
her son and wouldn't you know it the
sister calls Timmy up unexpectedly at
her recital to have him play something
sit back and enjoy the musical stylings
of Timothy green you know what running
late hit you do it's not okay for the
record just because you make one the
spawn of Satan doesn't make the other
one a good human being
so how would Timmy get out of this one
boom boom boom boom boom oh my friends
no no you know I remember when I paid
good money to hear Josh Groban and his
wonderful angelic voice but the spur of
the moment just whimsical magic he bent
over backwards and started Tooting a
horn out of his butt cheeks
it was butterflies in your stomach
awkward and sounded horrendous but at
least he was having fun
I got a fever and the only prescription
is my cabin so I guess the movie feels
they won that moment and the next day of
the game edgers father shows up and
starts to leave but his son guarantees
and that this time Timmy will be put in
the game because all season the coaches
and leaving him out is she different to
me today that is your game changer kid
right dry with clackum kidding
fuck puts her son in the game when did
see his nice birthday the old man we got
a game to win I'm sorry
why did coach Cal pick him if he knew he
was never gonna use him in the game
coach Cal has a sick sense of humor
Coach Cal likes to see children's dreams
get obliterated by Coach K no no see ok
he's an asshole hope he's okay but one
of the kids hurts their ankles and so he
does end up putting him in the game ok
Greinke oh stick they're not putting
that point and uh actually they are it's
good trust me keep drinking
I am so disgusted by this human emotion
you mortals call love at first he seems
to do little but then the Sun comes out
and
my sister four years of nursing how
perfect your kids are look at that hey
it is mine I could have been like that
because I had skills but no oh that's
what it's all about our kid
accomplishing goals set by other
people's standards and look he even
makes the winning shot or the other team
yeah that's right you thought that
cliche died with the 90s but nope Disney
brought it back do you get it though do
you get it in the opening they predicted
that their boy would shoot the winning
shot it just happened to be for the
other team no you should have been more
specific on your boy growing cards stop
your time's up
you have to last finish you have to hear
the whole thing you guys you have to
excuse me with all due respect we're not
leaving okay
that said it's your time to use as you
choose yeah the thing they don't show
you is this I decided that our son would
not be seen as different or weird he'd
be treated like a normal kid because
that's what he was called oming hi buddy
but it looks like you just broke up with
her no I let her go well that is so
tragic despite that breaking up and
letting go is essentially the same thing
but I'm sorry what does any of this have
to do with pencils this is a new kind of
pencil made almost entirely out of lead
I swear if someone doesn't fuck a pencil
by the time this movie is over only sure
it happens for yeah that will not only
save trees but will save our factories
but it turns out the boss the one
drinking the great big boss monkey see
he's the boss in case you forgot huh huh
huh he's the boss is taking credit for
creating the leaf pencil
but Timmy stands up and tells the truth
new pence was lauded by my parents Jim
and Cindy green Oh
before you kick the winning goal for the
other team children are to be mocked and
shamed
do not pick on my son if you ever so
much as even look at him funny you will
have to deal with me and me I'm here for
my last minute Redemption how did you
come up with this idea to make a pencil
out of leaves because I had leaves in my
life so they reveal that they must have
come up with the idea to make a pencil
out of leaves because well it's probably
made out of half of his kid I used to
have more but being the ever observant
douche pinatas that they are the parents
never noticed all this time that his
leaves were falling off and he finally
revealed that when the leaves go so does
he
sweetie you kid don't you so much do we
have left we're just starting to get
good at this you ready
you were always ready like my deck movie
there is ready to start a family as a
goddamn suicide Club
so he vanishes presumably going to the
grape fertilizer in the sky and are now
childless parents finished their tale
thank you I think that's all we need
that's it that please thank you I'm
going to call the phone service and get
the mental ward on speed dial so if you
work for an adoption agency and heard a
story that was so bizarre that even Rod
Serling would start chewing his balls
off in the middle of it all so taking
into account that the parents have done
nothing but proven how in competently
unprepared they are to take care of a
human being
why do you allow them to have a child in
their custody of course you would
I'm surprised I didn't given 6-10 help
half of the orphanage to look after yeah
I believe it
I fucking believe it Wow Wow
you know let's assume just for a moment
that this story that would have gotten
tons of media coverage didn't make it to
the attention of the adoption agency and
they did their research and found that
it checked out the reason that these two
should not be allowed to have a child is
explained in one scene shown earlier
what would you do differently we make
better mistakes better job to say new
new mistakes that's that's what we do
isn't that how you know you repair so
your argument is you fucked up you're
glad you fucked up and you will continue
to fuck up in new and spectacular ways
no no mistake so you can learn from them
not so you can make more mistakes are
you fucking high sure everybody messes
up it
to happen but it happened so you can get
better and make the right choices these
two never got better at what they did if
anything they just got worse and worse
why because they never learned that
you're supposed to learn you want a lot
of the most important things you can do
for your kid that these parents almost
never did throughout this entire film
ask your kid questions and think about
it they almost never did it right down
to where do they come from what do you
know say you seem to know a lot about
this stuff but seem very mysterious
about it would you mind telling us that
what are your light what are your
dislike fuck it we're signing you up for
soccer do you play any instruments
fucking go up there and play something
who's that girl I don't care stay away
from her it's why they never knew
anything well I can tell you that I know
something for sure this movie is a cock
salad I feel bad because I know the
actors are trying help the kid is
actually even pretty good at it but I'm
sorry no amount of acting skill can save
something this horribly put together it
knows what it wants to say but it has no
idea how to say it correctly it's a bad
vegetable that should be turned in for
better produce
I mean hey everybody should get a
practice kid before they get a real kid
to try out on well maybe not everyone
just they said selfish and it I'm gonna
stab the credit guy remember so you
don't have to keep your cat's away from
me
you
cause cow doesn't see
hey guys nostalgia critic here it's good
to be back especially after being and
that's a real plot hole I mean true the
accommodations could be nice but it does
weird things to your memory like there
was one point where I didn't even
recognize myself and I even started
going crazy reviewing all my old stuff
like kickassia suburban nights and to
boldly flee there was even a strange
moment where I thought they were not
good and even started making fun of them
and because you probably love to see me
make an ass of myself it's now available
on DVD for a limited time only you can
get nostalgia critic reloaded but it not
only has a review of the anniversary
films by yours truly it also has a live
review of Twilight Breaking Dawn two
other characters remembering the
nostalgia critic in fond and mostly non
fond ways the best nostalgia critic
moments that never happened featuring
egoraptor look at the original locations
and sets of the nostalgia critic and
more so what are you waiting for get
nostalgia critic reloaded on DVD while
they're still in stock and maybe you can
see me yeah loaded
you